steve how you been man i'm doing
excellent uh uh it's awesome to talk to
you today um whenever i am lucky enough
to talk to someone who's won an oscar i
ask the same question uh where do you
keep it
um well you know it's funny i always get
that question and i worked with denzel
washington and i asked him the same
question and he said
next to the other one
and uh and then he's asked me yeah where
do you keep it i said it by itself
okay i'll leave it there that's a great
answer um which of your friends and
family were most excited when you told
them you'd be playing a villain in a
james bond movie
uh
well man everybody got excited because
it's something that's just
it's
woven into our cinematic fabric in
history
it is it is the the greatest
franchise of cinema history you can
can't really argue with that
um and that's because
it's been
nurtured and really looked after it's
such a sacred part of uh
of cinema and it's been it's really been
looked after by some of the best people
you could you could ask to be running
that ship with barbara broccoli and
michael g wilson
do you think uh you've probably answered
this but i am curious do you think
elliot and your character in this have
any similarities or they're completely
different people
uh well i think they both find
themselves uh
uh dealing with the question of what it
means to be a hero what it means to be a
villain
um
you know i i like having uh nuanced
performances uh in my in my uh back
pocket all the time they're
they're the performances that resonate
with me the most and the ones i can
connect to the most uh i think for me it
was a lot easier to connect to elliot
than it ever was to safin he uh
his moral compass i i think is much
further removed than elliot's is
uh i love learning about the behind the
scenes of the making of movies and
television shows
everything um what do you think might
surprise people to learn about the
making of no time to die
uh
you know there were just moments where
if if things weren't
working as well as we all thought they
could you could take
time to talk to barbara and michael and
of course carrie fukanaga and daniel and
and have uh
good philosophical discussions about
what was important to see in the film
what was important for daniel uh of
course you know we really wanted to
celebrate him in in his final film so
i think keeping that
uh in the at the forefront of our minds
always was uh healthy responsible and
even if it took extra time
uh for us to negotiate those moments it
all ended up being so worth it uh if
you've seen the film
i i have i agree um listen thank you so
much for your time congrats on being
part of this film i wish you nothing but
the best
thanks man thank you so much